what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are covering Young Justice in
DC rebirth and to be honest Young
Justice is well I mean really it was
kind of after my time you know I pretty
much stopped watching comic book based
cartoon shows once extra in the animated
series in Batman the Animated Series
went off the air I do remember watching
Justice League no I didn't watch really
really watched Justice League Unlimited
but I watched Justice League I watched
Superman the animated series neither of
which was as good as Batman the Animated
Series and neither of those like none of
those were as good as xB in the animated
series sorry Batman fans it was a great
show but x-men the animated series was
better I'm curious which one you guys
think what's better x-men the animated
series or Batman the Animated Series I'm
gonna go with excellent but nonetheless
I do know there is a huge following for
Young Justice a lot of you guys lived on
this show like all of you guys read the
comics you guys loved the show the whole
nine yards and it's cool to see you know
it's cool to see that it's not that big
of a thing but what this does is really
kind of bring together the Young Justice
team but a little bit different from
what we're used to so those are guys who
were familiar with this concept bear
with me while I won over this for those
who aren't Young Justice was really an
answer to like what would happen if DC
created like a new version of Teen
Titans right because like the Teen
Titans as we knew them by the time Young
Justice popped up the Teen Titans had
stopped being the Teen Titans they had
aged up and they were distantly called
the Titans and so rather than creating a
new Teen Titans team right off the bat
DC launched Young Justice and they used
Superboy Conner Kent they use impulse
Bart Allen and they use Robin Tim Drake
and it was hugely popular it was really
really really really big now because of
the fact that it was Young Justice who
was the Young Justice League team DC and
turn used that to kind of like platform
into something bigger by basically
taking like all the teenage superheroes
that existed India or not really all of
them but like a huge portion of the Deen
teenage superheroes have existed in DC
at the time and like threw them on to
Young Justice and so because that it was
basically two Teen Titans for like a new
generation of people and again it was it
was it was very popular enough really
for a lot of fans they kind of found
common ground and like the teenage
nature of the titles of both Teen Titans
and Young Justice and the sense that
they dealt with teenage issues they
dealt with like young love and different
things like that struggle and so on and
so forth there is kind of a bay a debate
among the community in terms of which
one was more teen like in terms of like
dealing with teenage issues which one
was basically better Teen Titans or
Young Justice and you'll find out that
crowd kind of bickering amongst each
other they'll actually argue pretty
intensely I think they take it a little
more seriously than it should but
nonetheless
it's kind of cool to see these these
things kind of go back and forth but
this is being written by Brian Michael
Bendis and for those of you guys who are
not familiar with bindus but he's
literally second to none when it comes
to writing young people no one's as good
as he is he's just got a natural
penchant for doing it and so when he's
writing teen or is writing Young Justice
is exciting and so what this does is it
initially picks up with Ginni hex now
from my investigations I'm poking around
she's new here she's created here and
will actually find another character
created by Ben this leaves I'm pretty
sure in order to kind of flesh out the
roster but again right off the bat the
introduction of like the great great
granddaughter of Jonah Hex it was not an
original founding member of Young
Justice and this is smart because what
it is is this bindus basically saying
hey guys here's Young Justice coming
back but we're not retreading water
we're not doing the same thing you've
seen before because and the reason for
this is because in reality while Young
Justice as is being written out in
rebirth is done for the purpose of like
reaching out to the calm of a crowd and
saying hey look like here's like the new
young superhero team the reality of this
is that it's design it's happened to the
existing crowd of Young Justice readers
because you guys will be the first ones
to run to the comic book store and buy
it as it would that be in the case like
it has to be done in such a way to where
it gives you a return to familiarity but
it's not a carbon copy and so with this
kind of going on in the middle of all
this there's this huge invasion from
like another dimension from the twelve
the twelve kingdoms of gem world now in
reality like gym world is not new right
this is not Brian Michael Bendis like
inventing it out of thin air this all
goes back to like to 1983 actually an
amethyst self-titled book the princess
of gem world now the idea behind this
was that it was kinda like magic and
mystery and in DC's landscape but the
problem with this was that it only
lasted like a very very very short
amount of time it's that you only really
lasted I think until 1990 but between
the time it was cancelled in time that
it showed back up again amethyst and gem
roll appeared like a handful of times
over 18 years and then finally came back
in 2005 with Infinite Crisis but it
wasn't really until new 52 that amethyst
is the one really kind of got like a
reboot alongside everybody else kind of
a reworking of the story the problem is
that it lasted 18 issues and the sorcery
of swords miniseries and then DC
cancelled it because it was just that
unpopular the fact remains that with Jim
world showing up here again this is just
kind of Brian Michael Bendis tapping
into what was already an existing
landscape in DC Comics and so again Jim
rules had affiliations with like a lot
of different teams the Legion of
super-heroes
they've appeared in in
the young justice titles proper I mean
if they've had a pretty significant
involvement albeit sporadic throughout
DC but in the middle of this huge
invasion suddenly comes Tim Drake and
it's kind of cool here because the funny
thing about this is that with Tim
Drake's showing up again this kind of
like solidifies the notion of Young
Justice and it's kind of an interesting
choice to have Tim Drake's show up after
Ginny hex when you're talking about the
relaunch of an existing title which
proved itself to be wildly popular among
an existing readership it's usually the
main star of the title before it was
relaunched that shows up first the other
part of this is that normally Tim Drake
would be operating out of Gotham City
but at the moment some work that he has
going on has brought him to metropolis
which is where Ginny hexes and where
this whole invasion is going on but it
kind of flashes back to about four
minutes prior with Conner Kent meeting
with cassie sandsmark now again this is
kind of interesting because what it does
is it throws a little bit of the
continuity into into into play when it
comes to like the events of super suns
the idea that we saw cassie sandsmark
conner kent and impulse from the future
looking back into the past and then
trying to stop like that version of Tim
Drake from going crazy and so on and so
forth but it is kind of cool to see this
unfold because again Cassie if she
really ties into like the new 52 right
like DC rebooted her back in 2011 oh
really the idea of her being tied up
being that the daughter of Linux who was
like the half-brother I think of Wonder
Woman tied her directly to Wonder Woman
for the first time that I'm aware of but
she's kind of been free-floating and
sort of out there in DC albeit not as
active as you would expect throwing her
into Young Justice or the very least
featuring her here really kind of brings
her back into the fold this is like this
is how a lot of people know who or at
least how long he will want to see her
this is the world that she belongs in
Young Justice is where she needs to
stand out and so in the middle of all
this you have like that huge explosion
that goes on is so tender ik was in
Metropolis at the time the invasion
started and that's where he and santa
cassie sandsmark come from as always
kind of cool to see this unfold because
with the three of them really I guess
the two of them jumping in alongside
Jenny hex the team is starting to take
fold now one thing that also want you
guys to bear in mind here is how these
villains are written for the most part
they're written to be not really silly
but villains that you can't really take
seriously that's the nature of Young
Justice at the outset is the nature of
Bendis writing and it's the nature of
how this team is supposed to function
Young Justice is not supposed to be
silly right is it's not supposed to be
nonsensical it's not a goofy book but it
is designed to kind of focus more on the
heroes and less on the villains kind of
keeping things light kind of keeping
things pretty simple not getting too too
serious here again fans do want the
return to the serious stories of the
justise they do want to return to the
teenage themes but at the moment it's
really more of a celebration of the
team's return as opposed to why off the
bat people are dying or something like
that like we're not getting that you
know first the first case scenario from
here we pick up in Metropolis and we
have impulse showing up now Bart Allen
as far as I'm aware we don't know what
he's been doing since his return at the
end of flash work but the fact that he's
here and he's facing off against like
these various threats who were here
alongside like Tim Drake and alongside
cassie sandsmark and Ginny hexed this is
cool
because then suddenly we end up getting
team Lantern some new person who's got
the power of a Green Lantern who's
basically a teenager it's cool stuff we
get like these cool things sort of
coming together being brought together
and basically like impulse kind of
fulfills the role that we would that we
expected him to that's one of the things
to bear in mind that when it came to
impulse in the original Young Justice
stories he was kind of the standout star
for some fans because he was impulsive
he lived up to his namesake but he was
kind of like the comedic here the one
who was just kind of like let's just go
do things like let's just run in and
fight him and let's not plan anything
out and let's just see what happens you
know it was kind of fun in a lot of the
ways he was the voice of fans who really
are really I guess really the stand-in
for fans who like wanted to be
superheroes and this is why I say bindus
right so well is because and your
impulse is just like it's happening is
happening is happening and they're like
what an invasion it's like no no it's
happening it's happening Young Justice
is back it's really really cool it's
amazing to see because for so many young
really I guess older fans out there who
read Young Justice like this exactly how
they feel Young Justice is back holy cow
like young justice is finally here again
it's it's it's a time of celebration
it's a really really cool moment and so
that's when suddenly in the middle of
this whole conflict they basically all
started getting yanked away to these
different locations where I kind of
snapped away to these different either
dimensions or or locales or so on and so
it was Tim Drake is yanked to to gym
world or at least it seems like he
ejected gym world where he basically
meets up with amethyst and this is kind
of the cool thing because of the fact
that she was rebooted in new 52 but
because of the fact that she was
essentially extremely obscure to like
the casual come a book reader bindus can
kind of just clean slate amethyst if he
wants to and just start over and no
one's really gonna complain there's
gonna be very few people out there who
are gonna be like no amethyst needs to
be the way she was before and and for
those people I'm sorry to say but you
can be ignored and it'll be okay
like because she's not really that
relevant she wasn't really that
important I mean she was kind of there
and did some things whatever you know
but she wasn't by any means like the
biggest person ever I mean she was part
of Young Justice and served alongside
Young Justice but again like we're
talking about the post new 52 landscape
business can do a lot with her here and
so at the same time where impulse was
yanked away the others react to it we
don't really know where a lot of them
went to but we're impulse was yanked
away he's on this kind of weird desolate
place or what have you and ends up
running into counter hint and so at this
point Connor can't back Superboy is here
now and so it's cool because the team is
slowly taking shape the team is taking
form it's exciting it's a very exciting
issue to have here it's a very exciting
set of events because Young Justice is
essentially returning and again it's the
first story arc and so much like
traditional Binda storytelling this
first story arc will see the team
fighting together against the other the
threat of gym world it'll in however it
does and then Young Justice will
officially be reformed but let me know
what you guys think about the return of
Young Justice and DC commerce there know
how you guys feel about this but with
that being said we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here too
comments explained make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the rod for if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later purse
[Music]